OF WEDNESDAY APRIL 22ND.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
A LITTLE OVERVIEW, HERE’S WHERE
WE ARE AS OF 8:00 P.M. EASTERN,
WHICH IS TO SAY RIGHT NOW.
IN MANY PLACES IN THIS COUNTRY,
AMERICANS CANNOT GO TO THE PARK
WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
THEY CAN’T GO TO CHURCH, THEY
CAN’T HAVE FAMILY DINNERS WITH
OUR RELATIVES.
I CAN’T GO TO THE DENTIST, THEY
CAN’T GET ANY REPLACEMENT, THEY
CAN’T GET MARRIED.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF THEM CAN’T
AFFORD TO DO MUCH OF ANYTHING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THEY’RE
UNEMPLOYED.
BUT THEY BETTER NOT COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT.
IF THEY VOICE THEIR COMPLAINTS
ONLINE, THEY’RE LIABLE TO BE
CENSORED BY THE TECH COMPANIES.
IF THEY COMPLAIN IN PUBLIC, THEY
COULD BE ARRESTED.
AND A NUMBER OF THEM HAVE BEEN.
THE WINDOWS OF OUR POLITICAL
LEADERS ARE NOW UNQUESTIONED
LAW.
DISSENT HAS BEEN BANNED AND THAT
VAN IS RELENTLESSLY ENFORCED BY
THE WILLING STOOGES INTERMEDIATE
WILL FINALLY STOP PRETENDING
THEY DON’T HATE YOU, THEY
DEFINITELY DO.
WHAT COUNTRY IS THIS?
WELL, IT’S A COUNTRY IN A
LOCKDOWN.
WE ARE TOLD WE HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO DO THIS, TO STOP OUR
LIVES COMPLETELY.
THAT’S QUARANTINES, THEY TELL US
AGAIN AND AGAIN, ARE THE WAY TO
SAVE LIVES, BUT THAT’S A LIE.
THEY DON’T KNOW IT’S TRUE,
DESPITE WHAT THEY CLAIM.
IF THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC RECORD
TO CONSULT.
IT’S NEVER BEEN DONE.
WE ARE CURRENTLY LIVING TO THE
LARGEST AND MOST EXPENSIVE
EXPERIMENT EVER CONDUCTED IN
HUMAN HISTORY.
WE HAVE SPENT TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND CRUSHED MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE CURRENTLY ON THE GAS THAT
IS NATIONWIDE LOCKDOWN WOULD
SAVE US FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
HAS IT WORKED?
WAS THE GAS CORRECT?
LET’S LOOK AT THE DATA.
THAT’S WHERE WE SHOULD ALWAYS
BEGIN.
THAT’S WHAT OUR LEADERS SHOULD
BE CONSULTING DAILY.
HERE IT IS.
AS OF TONIGHT, EIGHT U.S. STATES
HAVE NOT ISSUED STATEWIDE
SHELTER-IN-PLACE ORDERS FOR THE
CITIZENS.
THOSE STATES ARE ARKANSAS, IOWA,
NEBRASKA, NORTH DAKOTA,
OKLAHOMA, SOUTH DAKOTA, UTAH AND
WYOMING.
THE QUESTION IS, HAVE THESE
STATES SUFFERED FOR NOT LOCKING
DOWN?
AND THE ANSWER IS NO.
THEY HAVEN’T.
AT LEAST NOT YET.
CURRENTLY ALL EIGHT STATES ARE
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN
CORONAVIRUS CASES AND DEATHS PER
CAPITA.
THAT’S NOT TO SAY THEY’VE BEEN
IMMUNE TO THE VIRUS.
THEY HAVEN’T BEEN, BUT THEY
DEFINITELY HAVE NOT BEEN HIT
HARDER THAN OTHER STATES.
NOW, AS A MATTER OF SOCIAL
SCIENCE, THOSE EIGHT STATES ARE,
IT IS TRUE, ON AVERAGE, SMALLER
AND LESS DENSE, IN SOME CASES
MUCH LESS DENSE THAN THE HARDEST
HIT STATES.
BUT YOU CAN ADJUST THE NUMBERS.
IN A RECENT ARTICLE, JOURNALIST
AND PROFESSOR WILFORD RILEY DID
THE MATH ON THIS.
HE COMPARED STATES THAT ARE
LOCKED DOWN WITH STATES THAT ARE
NOT LOCKED DOWN HE THEN RECORDED
STATISTICAL PROGRESSIONS FOR
DENSITY, INCOME LEVELS, AGE AND
RACIAL DIVERSITY.
HE PUT HIS FORMULAS RIGHT UP
THERE AND CHALLENGED PEOPLE TO
RUN THE SAME NUMBERS TO THOSE
FORMULAS OR CHANGE THEM, COME TO
A DIFFERENT CONCLUSION IF THEY
COULD, NO ONE HAS SO FAR.
HERE’S WHAT HE FOUND.
HE FOUND THAT A STATE’S LOCKDOWN
STRATEGY HAD VIRTUALLY NO EFFECT
ON HOW SEVERE ITS OUTBREAK OF
THE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS WAS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS?
MAYBE YOU SHOULDN’T BE.
YOU CAN SEE THE SAME TREND AT
WORK IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
SWEDEN MOST FAMOUSLY HAS NEVER
LOCKED DOWN.
STRONG’S THERE HAVE NEVER
CLOSED.
IF THAT COUNTRY IS STILL
SUFFERING FROM CORONAVIRUS,
SUFFERING MORE IN FACT THAN WE
ARE HERE IN THE U.S., BUT THE
COUNTRY’S EPIDEMIC APPEARS TO
HAVE PEAKED AND WITHOUT LOCKING
DOWN, SWEDEN -- AND THIS IS THE
KEY -- HAS FARED FAR BETTER THAN
OTHER EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT
DID LOCKDOWN.
THAT INCLUDES BRITAIN, ITALY,
SPAIN, BELGIUM.
HOW CAN THIS BE TRUE?
IT SEEMS TO CONTRAVENE
EVERYTHING WE HEAR ALL DAY LONG.
LOCKDOWNS STOP THE VIRUS.
THAT’S WHAT THEY TELL US ALMOST
ALWAYS AT HIGH VOLUME AND WITH
MAXIMUM OUTRAGE AND
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS.
DARING US TO DISAGREE.
BUT IN FACT THERE’S NOT MUCH
EVIDENCE THAT IT’S TRUE.
CONSIDER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
FIRST STATES TO SHUT DOWN.
IN A TELEVISED STATEMENT,
LOS ANGELES MAYOR BRAGGED THAT
HIS CITY WAS UNDER HIS ABSOLUTE
PERSONAL CONTROL AND FOR THAT
REASON, THE CORONAVIRUS WOULD
NOT SPREAD THERE.
ANYONE WHO DISOBEYED HIM WOULD
BE HUNTED DOWN.
IT’S LITERALLY THE PHRASE HE
USED.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS HAS REALLY BEEN
MARVELOUSLY EMBRACED BY 99.9% OF
PEOPLE.
WE SEE IT IN THE TRAFFIC DATA,
WE SEE IT IN THE CELL PHONE
DATA.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO HUNT DOWN
THAT LAST .1% AND STAKE GOT TO
GET INSIDE, YOU’VE GOT TO CUT IT
OUT AND YOU’VE GOT TO DISTANCE.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
HUNT DOWN PEOPLE WHO ARE
OUTSIDE?
THEY SPENT YEARS CALLING
DONALD TRUMP A FASCIST.
IF ONLY.
YOU MAY HAVE JUST HEARD, HE
BRAGS THAT HE WAS SURVEILLING
PEOPLE’S CARS AND TRACKING THEIR
CELL PHONE USE.
BUT EVEN THAT WASN’T FAR ENOUGH
FOR HIM.
GARCETTI ALSO INTENTIONALLY
RUINED CITY PARKS IN LOS ANGELES
JUST SO THAT NOBODY COULD USE
THEM WITHOUT HIS PERSONAL
AUTHORIZATION.
>> FOR INSTANCE THAT THE SKATE
PARK AT VENICE BEACH AND PEOPLE
WERE THERE, SO WE HAD TO PUT
SAND INTO THE SKATE PARK TO MAKE
THAT UNUSABLE FOR NOW.
WHEN WE COME OUT OF THIS WE WILL
CLEAN THAT STAND OUT.
>> Tucker: NO POTTER DOME OF
MODERN POLITICAL LEADER IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER TALKED LIKE THI
YET
SUDDENLY IN CITIES ACROSS THE
NATION SO MANY OF THEM ARE
TALKING JUST LIKE THAT.
IT’S AUTHORITARIAN.
HAS THIS NEW AUTHORITARIANISM
PRODUCED RESULTS APART FROM A
SURGE OF POWER FOR THE
POLITICIANS EXERCISING IT?
LET’S SEE.
AGAIN TO THE NUMBERS.
UNDER STUDY BY RESEARCHERS AT
USC, THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, AS DO LARGE
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR
LARGE ANTIBODIES.
THEY FOUND THAT AS OF EARLY
APRIL, UP TO 5.6% OF THE ENTIRE
ENTIRE COUNTY HAD CONTRACTED THE
ILLNESS.
THAT MEANS AFTER 320,000 ADULTS
IN LOS ANGELES APPARENTLY HAD
ALREADY HAD IT.
AT THE TIME, THE OFFICIAL NUMBER
OF INFECTED PEOPLE WAS ABOUT
8,000.
CITY OFFICIALS HAD NO CLUE.
THEY WEREN’T EVEN CLOSE.
THE VIRUS HAD SPREAD THROUGHOUT
A HUGE POPULATION RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
QUARANTINE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
IT TELLS YOU THE LOCKDOWN DIDN’T
WORK.
THE QUESTION IS WHY EXACTLY DID
IT FAIL, AND WE DON’T KNOW, WE
CAN ONLY GUESS.
MAYBE PEOPLE IGNORE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF IT.
OR MAYBE FULL ENFORCEMENT OF IT
WAS IMPOSSIBLE DESPITE THE FACT
THEY WERE TRACKING PEOPLE’S CARS
AND CELL PHONES.
OR MAYBE FORCING PEOPLE TO STAY
INSIDE ALL DAY ISN’T ACTUALLY A
GOOD WAY TO CONTAIN A VIRUS.
WHATEVER THE REASON THAT IT
FAILED, OUR LEADERS GUESSED
WRONG.
THEY CLAIMED THAT A LOCKDOWN
WOULD HALT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS.
IT DID NOT DO THAT.
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
AND THEY NEED TO ADMIT THAT.
AND THEN WE NEED TO CHANGE OUR
APPROACH BASED ON THE SCIENCE.
NOT ON THEIR WHIMS, ON THE
NUMBERS.
ON WHAT WAS LEARNED.
BUT WE ARE NOT DOING THAT.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS ARE INSTEAD BY
AND LARGE IGNORING ANY EVIDENCE
THAT INDICTS THEIR POLICIES OR
CRITICALLY THAT MIGHT THREATEN
THEIR NEW AND MUCH LOVED POWER.
THEY DON’T WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
FACTS ARE.
INDEED, SOME OF THEM ARE EVEN
NOW, RIGHT NOW, PROMISING EVEN
LONGER LOCKDOWNS.
ONES THAT EXTEND BABY TO THE END
OF THE SUMMER AND EVEN TOUGHER
PUNISHMENTS FOR THOSE WHO
DISOBEY THEM.
THEY ARE DEPLOYING DRONES TO
CATCH PEOPLE WHO DARE TO GO
OUTSIDE.
AMERICANS.
THIS IS INSANITY.
IT IS DEFINITELY -- AND THIS
CANNOT BE STATED EMPHATICALLY
ENOUGH -- IT IS DEFINITELY NOT
SCIENCE.
THIS IS NOT SCIENCE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
MUCH LESS THE BROADER PUBLIC
INTEREST.
THIS IS INSTEAD WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN MEDIOCRE PEOPLE SUDDENLY
FIND THEMSELVES WITH GODLIKE
POWER.
DECIDING WHO CAN GO OUTSIDE, ONE
PEOPLE CAN GET MARRIED, WHICH
MEDICAL PROCEDURES ARE ALLOWED
TO HAVE.
THAT’S A FEELING OF OMNIPOTENCE,
AND THEY LIKE THAT FEELING.
IT FILLS AN EMPTY PLACE INSIDE.
I DON’T WANT TO GIVE IT UP.
IF THEY TO LAST FOREVER.
EVEN AS THE COUNTRY DIES.
BUT IT CAN’T LAST FOREVER